hello and welcome to this video playing
muha 750 so it's back to back I had a
weird gambit line recently with see
takes deform it didn't turn out to be so
bad from black okay so it seems that
muha here is gone to the terrace without
really having any any knowledge because
this is already pretty awful
why does better now in many ways you can
take East 6 which is some fairly had a
huge advantage or you can take on c6
both as some yeah both is very good it's
a tough call I'll take him the problem
is that it's just the bishop is too
early here on c5 is one of the problems
let's see now I'm threatening Knight a
form and yeah yeah here I will get the
Bishop and c6 also hanging question is
do I just take it on
[Music]
I'm hesitating because I'm just going
before is also quite interesting let's
do this this also um seems quite nice
really hmm evil yeah you for is just
good from what
hmm okay
he's totally unimpressed it seems
pawn takes Queen d2 now takes birth the
bishop yeahi'm quincy 3 is one of the
good lines
sorry so let's see what he does now on I
have six okay okay if I cook yeah rookie
one there is nothing directly happening
on f2 but something to have to check
okay taking you 195 that's a tough call
what I wonder is if Bishop h3 next is an
idea yeah maybe preserve the bishop and
get get a little tempo there on the on
the rook okay a 45
right so one idea here is rookie five
intending rock g5 rookie five is also
threatening to take to take walk t5 it's
interesting
okay now rook g5 threatening Queen takes
it's not super convincing so a5 I can
also play combine all those ideas
Bishop III Queen c7 it's not so good so
let's prepare a 6 you can never play
Knight e4 as I just take it or you
piayed
maybe c5
Jim I thought that helped me a six-hour
move the rook away from from me five I
just wonder where where exactly - a one
maybe support the pawn on what is simply
bishop a three going to be strong it is
probably just strong yeah Bishop III
next and then a combination of rookie
is-7 and Bishop c5 yeah it's probably
strong
[Music]
just remove this from the slightly
exposed position he wants to go Queen f3
here
I have no time I've got absolutely no
time what did I do with my time in this
friggin game I mean it doesn't help - or
play the guy totally you have to also
win timewise I mean
I am just just two points down what the
game is really we just wouldn't like
half of the games where I'm totally
winning I would probably have 200 more
winning points or something
I mean games like that are really
impossible to not win almost but I am
constantly managed it's made I should be
shot for this I mean it was just like a
complete complete route yeah
from from start to finish basically and
then I'm totally losing the threat here
yeah Kim so this is a pretty awful
opening where white is better yeah you
can take c6 you can take it six this is
also very bad it's just a matter of what
you want to do now the light squares are
killed anyway but this is also clearly
better for white so it's not a not a
huge thing so then you remove the night
without any particular whatever allowing
e4 and now this is a structure where
white should just win yeah why at least
check and I think it's very close to him
to a winning advantage the engine is
just like on plus one which is yeah it's
moderate yeah would be five maybe maybe
that wasn't so great but I mean it is it
is a huge advantage and now just a
little bit of precision would be would
be enough to just win this so rook e1
queen fi
okay one f3 and now just a little bit
just a little bit one or two precise
moves and the game is just over so Queen
f3 Queen a three years winning okay now
this is not easier this this kind of
thing it's very likely that I can do
something better real rookie 7 is
immediately over not even sure why I
mean okay I'm covering this and he still
cannot move the knight and Queen f3
doesn't do anything okay I just a queen
d4 is just weird yeah just giving this
it's probably still winning one point
something yeah but now I completely
completely lost the threat here giving
giving this away and now you cannot care
that you cannot hold it's two points
completely losing the threat down
[Music]
yeah I took my way why did I am I should
probably want from me sometimes if they
play those dreadful openings I take too
long trying to trying to completely
refute it yeah like make it actually
what's doing this rather quickly how do
I have to read this yeah I took it took
really long around him yeah you should
just I should just play quicker there
it's it's something where I mean you're
better anyway so don't think for ages by
the way I just see after you did this I
can't do guy could take here right this
is just game over actually the air porn
will just win here probably I was a huge
miss okay guys thanks for watching